C'est un serpent de bitume au cœur de la nature,
À plus de 2000 mètres de haut.
On l'appelle l'autoroute du ciel.
L'autoroute Y Axis traverse la province du Sichuan. Entre Xinjiang et Yaan,
Il aura fallu un chantier colossal de cinq ans.
Au fil des kilomètres,
270 ponts enjambent vallées et cours d'eau et 25 tunnels perforent la montagne.
Des paysages à couper le souffle et surtout des cols difficiles.
Dont les camionneurs doivent triompher pour livrer leur cargaison.
Voici les principales missions de la journée.
YoushiGang, le chef de la brigade de l'autoroute briefe,
Son équipe comme tous les matins à 2400 mètres d'altitude.
Selon les prévisions,
Il va probablement neiger aujourd'hui.
Pendant les patrouilles,
Il va falloir vérifier la température de la chaussée.
Si un camion est en difficulté dans l'ascension,
Il faudra évidemment l'aider.
Liu a une vingtaine d'hommes sous ses ordres.
Ces agents de la circulation sont les anges gardiens de cette nouvelle route du thé.
Cela fait trois ans que l'officier Liu est en poste ici,
Et cette montagne enlacée par l'autoroute la conquis.
Sous cet angle là, la route est vraiment magnifique.
Regardez, il y a trois niveaux d'autoroute avec un dénivelé de 400m en seulement 11km.
Les architectes ont fait une prouesse extraordinaire.
C'est la plus belle route sur laquelle j'ai travaillé.
Quand il y a du brouillard, on a l'impression d'être au cœur des nuages.
C'est pour ça qu'on appelle cette route l'autoroute du ciel.
La grande fierté de l'officier Liu et de toute la région.
La voici.
Nous arrivons sur le fameux pont ****.
Il est unique en Chine en raison de sa structure,
Mais aussi à cause de l'endroit où il est implanté.
Des allures de grand huit et d'attractions foraines.
C'est un viaduc métallique long de deux kilomètres.
La géologie des lieux a empêché une construction en béton.
Il a fallu monter des tubes d'acier creux pour réduire le poids de l'ouvrage.
800 personnes ont été mobilisées pendant 3 ans à 110m de haut.
Le pont Genrizeu, fait maintenant l'admiration de tous ceux qui l'empruntent,
Comme l'officier Liu.
Je suis très fier de ce pont.
Et en plus, vous vous rendez compte,
Cet édifice est dans mon secteur.
Je passe tous les jours dessus.
C'est comme si c'était un collègue de travail.
Des milliers de camions circulent ici chaque jour.
Liu et son équipe ont en charge la partie la plus élevée de cette autoroute du ciel.
La plus dangereuse aussi.
Le dénivelé,
Plus de 7% et la longueur de l'ascension épuisent les machines et les conducteurs.
Thulin s'aventure ici deux fois par semaine.
Il transporte des fruits et des légumes.
Direction Chengdu,
La capitale de la province, à 600 kilomètres au Nord-Est Jie.
Le trajet me prenait une dizaine d'heures minimum avant l'autoroute,
Mais maintenant, j'arrive à le faire en 8 h.
Pour nous, les camionneurs,
Ça nous fait gagner beaucoup de temps.
Mais ce jour là, Thulin est inquiet.
Il débute son ascension qui va le mener à près de 2500m d'altitude.
Et la météo est en train de se gâter.
Il commence à neiger là.
En partant ce matin, je n'aurais jamais pensé qu'il allait neiger.
La météo est anormale cette année.
En général, il ne neige plus à cette période.
Regardez, il y en a partout.
On peut à peine rouler.
Il doit bientôt passer le fameux pont métallique à 110m de haut.
Bien sûr que j'ai peur de glisser.
Pour le dire franchement, dans ces conditions là,
Je pense souvent à mes deux enfants en bas âge.
Mais on est bien obligé de rouler, même avec cette météo.
Pendant des heures,
Thulin affronte les intempéries et la fatigue.
La neige ralentit considérablement son trajet.
Il ne peut plus continuer et doit s'arrêter pour la nuit.
On va se boire un petit verre, non?
Moi, je prendrais bien de l'alcool blanc.
Ce dîner imprévu est l'occasion de retrouver un collègue,
Et de goûter la spécialité locale la fondue du Sichuan.
Des légumes, des abats, des boulettes de porc,
Le tout dans un bouillon de bœuf.
Bonsoir Messieurs, je vous apporte les condiments.
Du navet, de la coriandre, de l'ail et de la ciboulette.
Merci, merci.
Tu veux du piment fort?
Non, tu peux me passer la louche.
Qu'est ce que j'ai faim?
Ça tombe bien, il y a beaucoup de viande.
Tu goûtes les boulettes?
Nous les routiers, nous passons quasiment notre vie dans la cabine.
C'est rare d'avoir des moments de détente comme ça.
Quand on est bloqué sur la route à cause d'une mauvaise météo comme aujourd'hui,
Un bon repas entre amis, c'est vraiment appréciable.
Un moment de convivialité rare pour celui qui passe la semaine seul dans son camion,
Loin de sa femme et de ses deux fils.
Une vie de solitaire et pas toujours confortable.
Pour 550€ par mois.
Le salaire moyen en Chine.
Je suis épuisé.
Je ne vais pas être long à dormir.
Le lendemain matin,
Thulin a repris la route depuis 2 h déjà.
Le soleil éclaire maintenant son trajet.
Un nouveau défi attend le chauffeur.
Une très longue descente.
Mais avant, un arrêt obligatoire.
Et l'agent Liu veille au grain.
À ce péage, chaque camion est pesé.
Le risque,
C'est qu'un véhicule surchargé ne puisse plus freiner,
Et ça pourrait avoir des conséquences dramatiques.
Avancez.
À partir d'ici, les véhicules vont descendre pendant 51 km.
Leur poids s'affiche sur cet écran là.
Et puis parfois, j'en profite pour rechercher aussi les matières dangereuses.
Je vais inspecter votre cargaison.
Thulin est déjà en retard.
Pourvu que l'officier Liu ne soit pas trop tatillon.
Vous transportez quoi là?
Des pastèques.
Des pastèques?
C'est bon. Levez la barrière pour ce camion.
Allez-y.
Le conducteur se lance dans la descente à flanc de montagne.
80 km/h maximum.
Surtout ne pas prendre de risques.
En fait, la pente n'est pas très raide.
Et comme ça dure pendant des dizaines de kilomètres,
Je dois faire attention à ce que le camion ne soit pas entraîné par son élan.
Vous savez, mon camion n'est pas chargé à bloc aujourd'hui,
Mais je m'inquiète quand même pour les disques de frein.
Ils doivent être constamment refroidis avec du liquide.
S'il n'y a plus d'eau ou que le tuyau est bouché,
Alors les disques risquent de chauffer et de causer un incendie.
51 kilomètres et une dizaine d'accidents chaque année.
Une descente redoutable pour les nerfs et pour la mécanique.
Je vais ajouter un peu d'eau là.
A voir la fumée qui se dégage de ses freins,
Il était plutôt temps.
Après la descente, Thulin aborde la dernière ligne droite de son parcours.
Dans la vallée cette fois.
Des kilomètres, dans un décor magistral.
C'est un lac artificiel avec un barrage en aval.
Vous voyez, le niveau de l'eau n'est pas très élevé en ce moment.
Sinon, ce serait encore beaucoup plus beau.
C'est vraiment la partie de la route que je trouve la plus jolie.
Ce que j'aime avec cette autoroute,
C'est qu'à chaque virage, je découvre un nouveau paysage.
Après avoir livré, Thulin repartira le lendemain avec une nouvelle cargaison.
La fameuse autoroute du ciel, poursuit elle, sa progression.
Vers l'ouest et le Tibet, cette fois.
Sur les traces de l'ancienne route du thé.
Rien n'arrête ce géant de béton et de bitume.
Pas même la montagne, régulièrement éventrée.
Bientôt, un nouvel ouvrage gigantesque verra le jour ici.
Pour faciliter le trajet des camionneurs comme Thulin.
Un ouvrage ou les ouvriers jouent pour l'instant les équilibristes à 120 m de haut.
C'est le pont Dadou Roué.
En contrebas, dans le village de Shing Shopping,
Les anciens ont un peu de mal à en croire leurs yeux.
Linh habite ici depuis 40 ans.
Sa maison est située en quelque sorte au carrefour de l'histoire.
À l'époque,
Les porteurs de la Route du thé passaient juste ici, devant chez moi.
Si on suit le chemin.
On voit encore leurs traces.
On peut encore voir les empreintes des cannes des porteurs sur les pierres.
Elles sont là bas, au pied de l'autoroute.
Dans quelques mois,
L'avenir de la région et de madame Linh se jouera plutôt en levant les yeux, cette fois,
Avec un ballet aérien de poids lourds.
En attendant que l'autoroute soit achevée,
Les chauffeurs doivent se contenter de la nationale.
Au fur et à mesure que la route s'élève vers le Tibet, les camions zigzaguent.
Dans cet écrin naturel.
Au sommet le ****, 4300 mètres.
Quasiment l'altitude du mont Blanc franchie par les 38 tonnes.
Mais la Chine voit toujours plus grand et plus fort.
Et peut être qu'un jour l'autoroute du ciel viendra jusqu'ici.
Colonisant les immenses plaines et bousculant la vie des yaks,
Et des habitants de cette région préservée.